hello is
that hold on thought I was
ready that's just the conference website
you guys have all seen
that all right hello uh I'm John Brown
and just want to say a quick thank you
to the organizers uh for putting this on
this is great this is my first time in
Berlin I'm really enjoying myself and uh
thanks to the sponsors for all of you
guys being here being a part of the
community and if you're watching this on
YouTube later
hello um what I'm here talk about is I
found a way to Center content both
horizontally and vertically in a simple
and semantically correct
way no no no no that's a lie that's a
lie total joke absolutely kidding I
don't know how to do that what I am here
to talk to you guys about is little
something that we created earlier in the
year uh using just CSS 3D so I just
pulled this up and I'll walk you guys
through it but this is just one element
flying around in the page and you can
see the I've got a laser too you can see
the just transform is going crazy over
here so I'll definitely walk you guys
through that and tell you how we made it
how we came to it and everything so
here's the agenda talk to you guys about
uh my T or my part with Google IO uh
I'll show you guys the experiment tell
you about how we made it the good things
and the bad things and I've got an
announcement at the end so CSS 3D
hopefully you guys since you guys are at
a CSS conference you guys at least have
basic understanding uh just of of again
of the simple Basics and if you don't
this is a colleague of mine who is at
CSS conf us last year uh he gives a
great talk about the basics and if
you're on YouTube click
here maybe they'll put a link annotation
in there I don't know uh so Google AO an
instrument this is where I work I'm a
technical director there we're a
creative agency and we have a lot of
really cool clients we about 100 people
or so and um we actually work in an old
ship building a ship building building
which is really awesome if you guys want
to look that up we've been doing work
with go with Google for about 5 years
and and uh I think we've done over 100
projects with them of varying sizes from
really small to really large and in
particular we have a really good
relationship with the io team and so if
you guys don't know what IO is it is a
annual developer conference that Google
puts on where they bring in developers
and they show them new hardware new
software uh apis and the uh the year
that we started this is in uh 2011 and
before the registration a couple months
before that we put up a teaser trailer
and it's an experimental website that
sort of gets people ready for the
conference so the first one we did was a
countdown clock these pieces would burst
apart and they' bounce around with
physics that was when physics was still
Super Rad sort of old school now uh and
then the next year we continued the
physics path we made uh some games with
levels you create your own and send to
your friends last year we rebranded it
completely and we had a binary game
where you had to enter in codes that you
sort of had to figure out or look on
Hacker News or whatever to unlock levels
uh like cat mode every website needs a
cat
mode so 2014 rolls around we're it's
January to go back to the drawing board
do some brainstorming some prototyping
Google is really great about letting us
come to them with ideas and then say
roll with it so they only had a couple
things that they wanted us to keep in
mind this year they wanted it to be
mobile first that's just the way of the
web uh more people are using mobile
primarily than ever before and that's
only going to go up they're also trying
to expand it to not just be for
developers they want to make uh make it
available for Tech enthusiasts and
especially designers so they didn't want
it so nerdy we've got binary games
physics puzzles keep it a little bit
more open so when we were looking
through getting inspiration doing
prototypes we ReDiscover the 's powers
of 10 so if you guys don't know what
this is it's a series of videos It's
actually two videos is two videos the
series we'll assume that is that came
out in 1977 the takes place uh starts at
a human scale it slowly zooms
out and it takes in encompasses all of
the universe in what we understand about
it this is will be slowly zooming
out and then once it gets to the
universe and tells you all the fun facts
about the galaxies it zooms back down
past the human scale and then it tells
you basically the understanding of the
smallest bits that we understood in 1977
down to particles and guessing about
subatomic
particles so we want to take this idea
of a sort of a journey from the micro to
the macro and since Google AO is annual
wanted to include a year in review of
tech and Science and the things that
Google are doing and Acquisitions that
they've made
so let's take a look at it a lot of you
guys have probably already seen this but
this is about a 45C version of
it uh when you actually go and check it
out you click and you move and you can
solve puzzles to go through it but this
is a very quick version of it just want
to show you guys it working there's a
lot of interesting pieces that go into
this so this is an iOS hedrin uh has 20
sides representing the 20 subatomic
particles and they're color coded to be
leptins or bans or whatever uh we were
very deliberate in in in uh making the
choices that we made
so this is the first chapter subatomic
it pulls up into an atomic level it's a
representation of a silicon molecule and
advancements that were made in
microprocessors then we look go up into
a humanish scale to look at some neural
networks and visual data learning RX uh
RX robot that uh Google sort of acquired
when they bought uh Boston Dynamics last
year this is a nod to the history of
communication Google Fiber and the
history of what's Google is going to be
sort of representing and then Voyager
just left the solar system last year uh
it's no longer being inundated with
solar wind so hopefully it's s to
discover really rad things in our
universe and then back to the
beginning so that was all in CSS 3D I
showed you guys that before you can
click on any of those elements explore
it see the transforms that are happening
but the thing that people keep asking us
is why did we do it in CSS
3D that's where I show you the demo how
do we get to CSS 3D why not do it in
webgl webg is awesome uh you can do
shaders and postprocessing and a lot of
really cool things but it's just not
ready for mobile it's only just now
going on iOS 8 next week I think uh it's
sort of hit or miss on the native
Android browser and Chrome for Android
you have to enable it explicitly I
think I'm not sure if that's still valid
but why not canvas the things that we
were running into
were it's too slow your phone doesn't
have as much processing power obviously
as yourp top or your desktop so we knew
that when we were doing our prototypes
it just wasn't going to cut it so we
turned to CSS 3D one everything can run
it and we can have fallbacks for it we
knew it's going to be a big challenge we
hadn't used it in such an interesting
experimental way before and all the
transitions get sched off onto the GPU
so what does that mean so CPU versus the
GPU so the CPU that you've got it has a
few cores but they're super powerful and
they can do all the calculations that
you want but the problem gets uh that
sort of like gets you is that when you
need to go paint those onto the screen
all those cores are still being used to
do all the calculations so you can get
really janky animations the GPU has a
ton of cores and they're not as powerful
and basically their sole purpose is to
just paint on the screen so you can
separate the logic from the actual
drawing and you can get super smooth
animations so you guys saw this on up on
the big screen and we'll show you guys
it on mobile I actually think it runs
better on mobile and we didn't do
anything to it we just uh it's the exact
same experience um with you know you can
pinch and zoom on it this is a quick CSS
trick for you guys this may be the only
practical information that I give you
other than just of talking about the
project so if you are using uh
Transitions and you're running into
problems where you're fading and sliding
and things start to get a little uh
chuggy you can just turn it into a 3D
transform and this will put it onto the
GPU it'll smooth everything out it is a
really great trick that I've used in a
ton of places and you you can actually
take that home use that tonight so write
it down but I'll also remind you later
and don't forget
prefixes so P CS is is awesome and I
would love to have had this whole thing
just be in CSS 3D alone I love going to
cepin and looking at all the rad
projects and seeing that JS panel with
nothing in it uh but we knew we had
State we had to take care of we had
interactions we had a lot of really
weird things that we knew we were going
to need to do so we use 3js which is by
far my favorite piece of job JavaScript
and a lot of people don't know that it
has a CSS 3D renderer where can do the
calculations and then directly apply
those uh output as animations to your
elements everybody knows about the web
GL and the canvas and if you've ever
used those the syntax is super similar
so you can actually go home and start
trying it
out if you don't know this is as easy as
it gets you add a camera you add a scene
they start rendering that scene that's
that is how you get
started but like I said we had a lot of
State we needed to keep keep track of we
had transitions if you go look at it
it's got
sound so we made so we created a
framework we named it after Carl Sean uh
you saw Voyager in there and I've always
wanted to name something after Carl Sean
so this is my
chance we created it it's got 9,200
lines of SASS and JavaScript I don't
know if that means anything in today's
society but that's a lot of lines uh for
mostly just two people working on it um
controls the state the sounds and the
Transitions and just to show you guys a
very like highle version of what that is
so for the icosahedron that you saw in
that first Bon chapter you create your
class and this inherits behaviors and
Transitions and then you create your
chapter and then you add those entities
that can then also have entities inside
of them and then you put it in the
chapter stack and then you walk through
it those powers of
10 all right let's talk about the really
cool oh really cool things that we
did I wasn't going to swear
um so we wanted to make these 2D
citizens living in this 3D world uh look
like origami we wanted to give them some
character and some depth so any entity
that's on the page any element we can
call foldable on it and it duplicates
that content and then translates it
makes it half the width and then puts
them back together so they look sort of
move around like a book you guys saw a
little bit of that it moved really
fast you can also assign patterns to
them and then so that one on the very
right is flipping through the CSS com
colors uh really simply you can Fold It
blink it uh it originally had the
ability that you could uh rotate it on
different axes but we ended up not using
it so I stripped it out this is a lot of
fun to do and it took a lot of trial and
error and there's some things that I can
talk to you about why that
is so elements don't really understand
physics they they don't bounce around if
you say bounce they don't understand
lights you can add a shadow to them but
that's kind of dumb it doesn't really uh
it doesn't not dumb it's like it it's
unintelligent so we ended up adding uh
expanding that shadow information we use
box Shadow we could we use drop
shadow and we could as well and
sometimes we would just duplicate those
divs flood them in color and then shift
them
around
sorry
so the one on the right is rotating and
it's had it has the CSS transform
applied to its shadow that's running
around in the background and what that
looks like if it were sort of standing
still and just that shadow is rotating
is on the left so whenever you needed to
apply an animation to an element you'd
also apply that offset by whatever that
dimensionality is and then put it back
on the and put it on the
shadow this made us be able to ground
all these element elements in this huge
white world and really added a lot of
depth and I increased the color on these
Shadows so so they would pop out at
you shading is awesome and again doesn't
really work because the your CSS
elements don't understand what that is
what we ended up doing is using a
concept from you know Game Theory where
you've got your plane and you've got a
normal which if you guys don't know what
that is it's the perpendicular Point
coming off of the flat surface you can
use that to calculate uh how much light
or reflection something should have and
we ended up using the brightness filter
again where we could to as things were
moving away from the camera adjust that
brightness I'll show that
again so these just a couple of items
that are sort of floating around in
space or these pages are flipping it's
not as easy as just adding a rotation y
to it or checking what the rotation Y is
and then adding that percentage because
as with you see with this guy
it's already at a 45° angle so if we
were using the same 45° 45° angle as
this when it was at 90° it'd be all
black but that's not what you want
because the light is coming from the
front so we use uh 3js to calculate we
walk up that parent tree figure out
where the plane was actually facing and
then we would apply our brightness to it
and the weird thing about brightness is
that one is actually like all black
which doesn't make sense to me
we also created an SVG compiler uh in
much the same way as you create uh a
JavaScript or css one uh CSS minifier it
will put it all into a Json blob that
you can then add them in line and uh and
adjust the view box and apply it and
figure out exactly that entity size and
the fluidity of it one of the things
that is hard to do with SGS in a
situation like this is if you want to
have a clipping mask and it it looks at
the ID if you've got two of the entities
that are using the same uh scg
information these start animating the
clip path on this one and it's using the
ID to to view that clip path this one's
also going to react because it's looking
for that ID so that sort of Cascades
down so whenever we added an SVG in line
we ended up creating a unique ID for
every element that needed an ID inside
of that STG when we put it in line so we
didn't have those
conflicts when we were doing animations
or clip
paths another Triumph is it runs like a
dream uh we had so many people who only
ever saw it on mobile tell us that they
they thought it was a video they
couldn't understand why it was moving so
fast and again the we didn't degrade the
experience it just runs super great
because those because of that GPU CPU
separation this is a home run for us
this we really nailed the mobile first
aspect of the project
I just closed my
slides hold
on all right I'm GNA Vamp for a second
when I pull this
up does this count as computer
trouble I'm G to say this counts as
computer trouble
also SL iio we were on google.com not
even a subdomain SL two letters and
probably the most two recognizable
letters in computer science is super
humbling experience to work with those
guys this year and I'm really proud of
the whole project also my wife made a
exoplanet cookies for us for our launch
and they were really
delicious so those are the good things
that we did and what went wrong plenty
always goes wrong that is just a fact of
every project uh so what are some of the
big ones intersection o oil and
water divs in 3D space we saw didn't
really want to interact so these two
elements are sitting exactly on top of
each other and then rotated a little bit
and they're inside of a parent div that
then is rotated just so you can see the
dimensionality of it so it doesn't
really look like what we'd expect we'd
expect these two things to be
interacting and intersecting with each
other so if we just move this one back
in zspace now all a sudden the water's
in front the oil and the water they're
not
mixing we designed around this uh we
made sure that the experience didn't
involve any intersecting
divs oh I almost closed all of chrome
that
time oh wait no that's fine I can close
that one leave this
page
but we developed in Chrome not because
it was a Google project if that's what
we prefer to develop in but you got to
make sure to check your other browsers
and here's
why oil and water mixing it's making an
Emulsion what does this even mean uh so
these two this is the exact same uh code
pen that I just showed you guys let's
make an let's make this animate so these
are actually moving into and out of each
other super fluidly and we discover this
shortly after we started designing
around all the intersection aspects so I
used to not be the person that would
read specs but now I am and here's and
this is one very good reason why
um what's
happening we'll open this up again
that's this isn't
Safari I should had jokes ready for
this respect the spec uh Safari is
actually correct so this is a supporting
dock from the from the specs of what
should happen when two things intersect
in 3D space so when two elements
intersect you split it and essentially
you have now four pieces that you need
to draw so the orange gets split the
blue gets split and then uses an
algorithm to determine what needs to be
drawn first so the skinny orange and
then the left blue with the right blue
and the orange in the back so just be
aware of this you guys probably won't
run into weird inter seting elements
very often uh but if you're trying to do
something weird and experimental this is
definitely something to be aware
of I put this slide in here because I
was afraid it's going to be the only one
complaining about Internet Explorer but
I think we're potentially like five for
five for five
so preserve 3D is essentially what makes
these 3D worlds possible it's not
supported in IE 10 and so what it does
is if you have an element and you rotate
at 45° you put it inside of a parel
element you take that 45° it should now
be at
90° but there's not the ability to have
that preserved 3D transform in IE it uh
so what does this look like it's a
little weird to describe so it's this is
a render from an from Internet Explorer
it's sort of like an mcra painting where
you've got dimensionality and you expect
things to go behind each other but
they're actually going in front
especially if you're trying to control
it it's just a little disorienting so
let it wash over you
guys so how do we get around that
actually
first uh it'll be an i 11 so don't worry
nope never mind not an i11 it's actually
still in development despite the fact
it's been in every browser for really
quite a while that's just an issue so
Microsoft suggests that you take your
element that you want to be 3D
transformed and you walk up stack and
you calculate all of the Transitions and
the rotations and then add them together
and then apply it it's super super high
uh it's super expensive and takes a lot
of work but thankfully uh 3js has a
explicit renderer for IE that only does
that it doesn't run as great but people
in using Internet Explorer just sort of
expect that thing
so make sure make sure that you put a
switch statement in
here another thing is that we're not
using webgl so you can't just throw
100,000 entities on your stage we ran
into about issues when we were pushing
around 70 or so and that depends on the
complexity of with they're like super
dense svgs or anything like that so if
you guys are starting to explore around
with this uh no amount of putting it
into 3D will help you because you're
already in 3D so you may get some janky
uh
animations and the last one isn't really
code based uh but I remember the very
first time we were ready to start having
somebody sort of use the experience so
we had the Silicon the second chapter
already and I put it into somebody's
hands and I sort of took a step back and
I watched them take the phone and go and
they just swiped it and spun and they
were like cool and it had sound to it
they swipe it and it spun and swipe
swipe swipe spin spin
spin they just stood there and I
thinking click it just click it to
progress down the journey and then they
paused did the thing that we all dread
they looked at me in the eye and they
said I think it's broken and I was just
like oh okay it's not broken but we made
it broken um we when we made this
journey we wanted to be self-exploratory
so it didn't say click here or have a
play button and you sort of felt like
you were a part of the world and un
unraveling it and going through it but
the problem with that is that users need
these uh these paradigms and these short
hands that we've given them over all
these Years cuz some people aren't
explorers and they'll get to a page and
they'll be like I don't know what to do
here close and the only reason this
young lady actually continued to swipe
it just because I was you know hovering
over her and being like how do you like
it so if you do do things that are
really experimental make sure that you
have a way that the user can enjoy it no
matter what their level of comfort is
with exploration we went back to the
drawing board and you can go through the
whole uh through the whole experience
using swipe
tap pinch uh click essentially anything
you do to it will progress the journey
but you feel like everything you're
doing is intuitive so you get this like
dopamine hit of like oh I'm actually
exploring this world and I'm doing it
correctly there's no barriers to entry
so again not something you guys will
probably see on a day-to-day basis but
if you do sort of experiment with these
things just be aware of these paradigms
that we've put in place for a reason
okay you guys are thinking
is he going to close this browser again
but you guys are probably also thinking
he made an SVG compiler that's cool and
there's these foldable entities but he's
got he's got cookies and how how do I
get access to any of these things the
cookies are gone we ate those but there
when I was talking to see uh to the
people at Google about coming here and
talking to you guys they said oh do you
guys want to open source it so we said
yeah I've never worked with Google in a
capacity where they' said just take it
and give away the code uh and it's super
awesome so I want to say thank you to
them in case they're watching this
yeah so that's up on the instrument uh
repo you can go to it here and uh you
can compile it change it add some new
levels some new powers of 10 steps if
you want to just let me know if you do
anything interesting with it okay I'm
nearing the end of my talk what are some
takeway from this I didn't give you guys
a lot of code examples so here's the
four things you should walk away with
CSS 3D is mobile friendly you should be
using it it is
awesome translate 3D code uh to un Jank
your transitions in 2D if you're ever
having an issue with that beware
intersections in 3D space make sure that
you at least at this point plan on
things not intersecting correctly in
most browsers and watch your users and
learn from them from the very beginning
you want to make make sure that as you
go down these paths that you're creating
something that everybody could
enjoy so thank you to you guys all for
listening uh thank you on YouTube for
making it all the way through uh I'm
John Brown at this is John Brown These
slides will be up on slides.com thisis
John Brown I'm ungoogleable but if you
search for this is John Brown this is
how you can find me uh so let's go have
lunch everybody thanks
guys